addressing homelessness here in the
valley new funding is headed to several
local groups to try and get people off
the street Lauren Grady live in The
Newsroom this morning with how this
money will be used Lauren
good morning John well it's thanks to
more than 14 million dollars in federal
funding the money is being distributed
to different state county and City
groups I spoke with Nevada Health
Centers they're expecting more than 2.5
million dollars that will help them
expand their services they provide
Primary Health Care for those who are
underserved and uninsured one program
getting a boost is their medical office
on wheels
it is a mobile medical vehicle that
supports our communities in the Las
Vegas area it is a collaboration to
serve a population of underserved youth
at-risk homeless youth including those
who have been exploited sexually or sex
trafficked
they call it the big blue the van serves
kids and young adults up to 21. they
work exclusively with four partners and
park at their sites Catholic Charities
Nevada partnership for homeless youth
embracing project and WIC Tropicana now
the July calendar isn't quite finalized
yet with Clark County staff members say
the money will be distributed over the
next three years live in The Newsroom
Lauren negretti 8 News Now